on our front doorstep blessing memory
and dream we'll never get to see their
father again not only was he a girl dad
he was a loving husband caring brother
and most importantly to me uncle I could
depend on Rashad Bruce was silly
he had the brightest smile and the
biggest heart and loved to dance since
we were kids
me and my uncle are both 27 years of age
27 years of age no one walking this
green earth expects to be shot and
killed like trash in the street for
falling asleep in a drive-through Rashad
has a family who loves him who would
have gladly came and got him so he could
be here with us today
the day after after my uncle's murder
his oldest daughter said for her father
and her birthday dress to come and took
her skating and to look across the room
and know that it's never a possibility
anymore breaks my heart
me and my family are still grieving the
loss of my grandmother when my uncle's
life was horrific Lee taken away from us
not only are we hurt we are angry when
does it stop we're not only pleading for
justice
we're pleading for change zone 3 where
my uncle was killed it's the same song
we represent and loved all our lives we
stood with the Lana Police Department
when they were just tearing up our city
and said this doesn't happen here leave
them alone and here we are three weeks
later those same police took something
away from my family that we'll never get
back Rashad Brooks most of us haven't
slept or eaten since we viewed a video
of a man being murdered to only get a
phone call moments later since he'll you
it's your loved one this entire
situation has traumatized me and my
entire family I'm sure for the rest of
our lives
my uncle did not die in vain his life
matter George always life matter
Rihanna Taylor's life matter Michael
Browns life matter Sandra Bland's life
matter I'm not only asking the city of
Atlanta to stand with this I'm pastor
for everyone in this nation to stand
with this as we seek justice for Rashad
thank you know you hear from his cousin
tiara Brooks Rashad Brooks the name that
may start a protest tomorrow or another
day in the future however the man
himself no longer has a future he can no
longer live in the present nor plan for
tomorrow no matter what the different
points of view are ours of his death we
must all agree to one fact the fact that
he was killed by the Atlanta Police
Department the fact that someone's
cousin brother uncle nephew father
companion and friend is no longer in
this world the trust that we have with
the police force is broken
and the only way to heal some of these
wounds is through a conviction and a
drastic change with the police
department mmm but honestly true true
justice would never prevail because we
will never be able to bring back Rashad
Brooks he will no longer be able to
return to this world nor to his family
however again if we stand together and
United as one there will be no more
cases similar to Rashad's how many more
protests will it take
to ensure that the next victim isn't
your cousin your brother your uncle your
nephew your friend or your companion so
that we can finally end the suffering of
police excessive force we are tired guys
we're tired and we are frustrated most
importantly were heartbroken so we need
justice for Rashad Brooks
this is a mr. Brooks his cousin his name
is mr. Allen gonna try to make this
brief and clear first and foremost we
want to say want to show our
appreciation and thanks to everybody
that's been out here supporting us and
helping us and we encourage you to
continue to do so and I actually go by
the name of the Cato read a lot of
people know me asked that a lot of
celebrities I see that been trying to
reach out and try to find a family we
are the family I am the family and if
you're trying to help you know reach out
to me so we can try to make sure that my
cousin and his wife and his kids is
taken care of
if you can't help financially you didn't
try to just keep helping with it with
your voice and stay with the protest but
again I want to just tell you that we
appreciate so make sure you get a good
[Music]
borders have been gradually reopening
after the pandemic but how easy it is
really to travel to another country
these days we're about to find out
what's in the news change these that
it's not cheap it's not sustainable and
it's probably not justified is this that
I personally I didn't feel comfortable
using so we travel business in Israel so
we get to stress also conditioning
really hope another problem is the
laboratories for health and safety
visions only the crew can use the front
so everyone even business best positives
configure so that they want to
he's heard of us
[Music]
we picked up luggage and we're on our
way back from work that we're gonna have
to stay in for about 24 hours until the
result of the test come see the
authorities after a coalesced would have
given them my heart phone number the
threshold would be staying obviously if
the test is positive I would have to be
everything
overall you know it wasn't a very
pleasant experience closed duty-free
shops are long delay to get the test so
it was a hassle but if you if you want
network somewhere either for holiday for
business reasons it's doable it's not a
huge fan of it it's not a disaster at
least that was my experience we might
just be powerful we might just be
beautiful
[Music]
we might just be
I'm a deaf dancer so I use dance as my
way to express myself to share how I
feel with the pain and the struggle that
we're going through and hoping that we
can come to a common ground of equal we
are practicing for the Jew Tina event
that's happening June 19th
this is our first event denkova 19 and
I'm very excited for my company to be
performing and show them that we are
here to support our community this
movement there's this day june team for
me it has become a day to celebrate the
freedom of all Americans it is a day
that I think gets pushed into being a
black day when instead it is just
another day in American history that we
all should be aware of and should
celebrate collectively as people watch
this performance I want them to feel the
connection with the poem and the music
and the movement that we're a couple and
we might just be powerful we might just
be beautiful
[Music]
I'm a deaf dancer so I use dance as my
way to express myself to share how I
feel with the pain and the struggle that
we're going through and hoping that we
can come to a common ground of equal we
are practicing for the Jew Tina's event
that's happening June 19th
this is our first event tank over 90 the
protestor before that's what we're
demanding it's not just laws and policy
changes but a mental change in policing
which is missing so we do want everybody
support we're looking forward to the
DA's findings in this situation and the
only thing that we can ask for is some
semblance of an idea of justice because
there is no definition anymore of what
it is but what we know right now
is that a man's life was taken when it
should never have happened right now we
want to introduce everyone to Tamika who
many of you have met and the kids
blessing memory and dream blessing it
was her eighth birthday when her father
died she had her birthday party on the
same exact day that they found out that
their father was killed she had her
birthday dress on as all of you have
heard she had cupcakes and friends over
she was supposed to go skating with her
dad and that didn't happen of course so
also also makai who's 13 is his stepson
and he took care of him as well
and Tamika if you want to say if he were
just want to thank everybody for all the
protests in love and support that you
guys have done I can't words can't
explain how thankful I am for everything
even though I can't bring my husband
back I know he's down smiling because
his name will forever be remembered
and no there's no justice that can ever
make me feel happy about what's been
done I can never get my husband back I
can never get my best friend I can never
tell my daughter oh he's coming to take
you scared
what swimming lessons so it's just gonna
be a long time before I heal it's gonna
be a long time before this family here
that's like I said I'm just thankful for
everything that everyone is out there
doing and I just ask that if you could
just keep it as a peaceful protest that
would that would be wonderful because we
want to keep his name positive and great
lastly we do want to acknowledge and
thank Tyler Perry who we spoke with who
will be taking care of the funeral for
the family and its support like that and
it's people who are actually in this
community that love the communities that
want healing and families like this to
never have to go through something like
this to step forward and we want to
thank him for such a generous move
yeah three brief questions we've had our
[Music]
tattoos and I'm scared every day my
children go out my husband go out my
family members and Christian that con is
it goes to a point of people are asking
well why would he resist when they were
trying to put him in handcuffs well they
put George Floyd in handcuffs and he was
subsequently killed so just getting put
in handcuffs if you're african-american
doesn't mean oh you're gonna get nicely
taken to the back of a police car so
especially watching this video of
Georgia over and over again we his
reaction may have been I'm not getting
put in handcuffs so we can't just toss
that out because he resisted George
Floyd didn't and it ended the same way
and this is this is something that is
not new it's not just with this George
Floyd all of us all of us I know every
black man standing behind me and woman
too we have all been dealing with this
from birth so that's a trauma that is
deep it's it's not something that just
started two months ago I still today
dress like our dress do what I do I
still feel nervous around police and
that shouldn't be the case all right and
so if you if you feel that way and then
you see all of these things happening of
course you're gonna feel some kind of
way when the police come up to you and
you know you you are somewhere where you
know you're not in the perfect state of
mind at that
anytime
it makes you eat your words I love it
laughing my family loves away and when
they were tearing busting out the
windows at CNN center we were like why
are they doing this to our city burning
down police cars why are they burning
police cars this doesn't happen in our
city and it our front door so not only
does it happen in our city it happens in
cities everywhere
[Music]
my name is tomato Brooks ray short this
is my first cousin these people that you
see behind you
my sister's his brothers his nieces
nephews its first cousins a week and a
half ago me and his older brother were
playing chess and he just popped up and
I said could I how you doing man you
could say yeah I came because I need to
see my wife and my baby man without a
birthday I see you stand out of trouble
your ID see I'm fine cuz I'm all right
we shared a few drinks a few laughs his
big brother gave him a few dollars any
left he was always happy he was always
smiling in your nightie killing I won
his family members cuz he wasn't that
type of dude so so you people that are
looking around the world and did you
have your feelings before it happened to
us I could only guess it what you felt
but now I understand life shouldn't be
this complicated life shouldn't be where
we have to feel some type of way if we
see a police or somebody of a different
color I didn't come down here to talk to
the media I came and loved all my people
but if you ask how old this young black
man was look at your children when you
see them laugh that innocence that joy
that pureness of soul
and you had a glimpse of what we lost
you have a glimpse of what it feels like
because tomorrow
we don't have to deal with it again we
gonna have to bear and we want to say we
miss you and if we didn't say we love
you enough
we gotta apologize to her for not
telling them that we love them that much
[Music]
I'm really not sure what else America
needs to see want to rerun a George
Floyd exactly I'm probably gonna be back
here in a few months
what another case
I gotcha
yes I did they they said they would do
that but head of time but I haven't got
a response saying that they did it weird
only okay
she doesn't have I being so Matic you
I can dial in
I wish I brought it it's in my car
okay a lot of them have I hope we were